in this video every minute someone
randomly explodes what wait that was
perfect typing so last time you hit all
three of us but sometimes it's only
gonna do one
so there's conveniently a village right
beside spawn I bet car blows up next is
conveniently in up site oh if it's me
this whole trees going why do I have a
feeling I'm gonna explode so much more
than you guys wait guys come near me if
I explode I don't want to lose
everything I'm getting away from Chris I
think he's next it's literally just me
alright so this video is gonna be a
montage of Carl dying Chris Carl you're
probably wondering what's our objective
what is our objective we were going to
beat Minecraft we are yes which ended up
itself is pretty hard pulling your
randomly exploding every minute it's
insane
we're not Chris hey I'm gonna go loot
this is Jimmy's map maybe it just
doesn't explode him ever yeah I wrote
that in the program guys guys how about
we outsmart the server well huh we have
technology I'm gonna start a timer on
the phone so I can count down before
some flows up oh my gosh the
anticipation is killing me alright I'm
accepting my defeat I'm standing in the
middle oh yes with the car it was Carl
every time we have 55 seconds until some
blows up again go quick
dude I was near so many trees and they
all exploded I got so much wood out of
that gross trap yes
someone's gonna explode in ten seconds
everyone brace yourself I need to get up
top oh I'll make this sword before I
explode wait I didn't die
hey I didn't die no the creeper blew up
on me but I didn't die probably gives
you the luckiest person in the world all
right I survived death I'm digging
straight down and I know that's not
[Music]
I mean
death came back for a visit Jimmy I
deserved that one
oh shoot oh gosh help us in the server
that was a real creeper thanks sis do
you like we should all stay together no
I feel like that's the opposite we'll
blow each other up good for seconds I
don't have enough wood for a chest I
hope it's not all three that timer's a
little hot but hey Carl
I'm so mad why does this keep happening
only to me how all right you can't die
oh but I can you can't explode if you
die to a skeleton that's true Pro stress
if I die I'm gonna be sad oh it never
happens to you if you're wondering why
Chandler's not here him and his
girlfriend went on a vacation for the
weekend so quite romantic actually
yeah but he puts the boys off to the
side yeah what's more romantic than
Minecraft with the boys minecraft
oh don't worry guys what do you again
Josh he keeps dying dude this is fun for
me I'm yeah I'm having a good time I'm
actually up to like 12 hours ah I love
how there's craters all over spot okay
did you get blown up again yes I did
Chris has it been like 20 minutes since
you died
do we hurt each other oh yes thank you
for confirming Carl how can you be in
charge of everything Chris is the only
person that will ever need foods this
entire game stop my stuff I want my
stomach to you I don't want my stuff why
would you give me a sword all right
oh no no I'm just kidding oh I mean it's
not only you it's just mainly you just
like 90% you finish the game I'll just
distract death sounds like he's salty
Carl can you just stay in spawn and die
for us yes dang it I had so much stuff
on me please don't take my stuff
no we're putting it all on the chest
we're working together guys okay okay
okay
we're being friendly and helpful yes
like what is for all of us to win the
game just make sure you guys get away
from the stuff before you explode it's
so funny when it's not me yep which is
every time so to beat the game agai go
to the nether mm-hmm we need a diamond
pick dig down here and if I explode
that's even better only the prices go up
exactly how do we get back down there
don't think about that oh of course
don't worry it was just Karl all right
Chris sorry we have one minute Chris to
trap the cows why why did it do that
what if you do it you don't know what is
it doing Chris grass I'm running I'm
sorry I tried fix the fences you're all
fan no all right here we go Chris get
away get away get away get away
watch watch Jimmy just stop you kill
them what do you think get away get away
get away get away meme 14 exempt me that
means you're making about hey why'd you
take out my stuff I was right here yeah
you took all my stuff you're tearing
this family apart
yeah that's not a way to talk to your
mom look up they will not move these
cows are actually trying to kill me I'm
pretty sure please do me I'm literally
asking me it to explode me please
minecraft gods I'm finally using it to
my advantage
explode me do it
I don't even care I hope I'm standing
near these Cal's house oh my gosh get a
rescue squad to go get our buckets
content over anything all right are we
good thank you
he blew a hole in the ceiling which
caused the Sun to come down and kill the
skeleton shooting me me and Carl focus
on strip mining yeah
thank you for blowing a hole thank you I
would have appreciated do you think I
just sit there staring at it all day I
would think so since it's in front of
you there good we have to get to the
nether we don't have to be prepared we
just have to get to the nether right I
know we just have to you survived I
survived I saw that nice also my timer
is no longer on my phone done I feel
like it's been close to a minute
underwater yes I figured out a cheat
code okay Jimmy you and I figured out a
cheat code hey girl we did that all
around I did this right now you would
think a war with out here these craters
this little patch right here oh it cows
okay so we figured it out right all we
have to do is make an underwater base
and then we can just swim outside and
then we'll be good okay that didn't
protect me we're close to the nether and
then we still have to kill the Ender
Dragon in the next video let the cows oh
I think it's funny that it was never
Chris and now it's almost exclusively
Chris I think he's getting madder than
you were when I was just you it's okay
Chris it's gonna be okay
oh I think he's about to quit crystal
why is it only me
oh look all my stuff got burned by lava
good same here
it's ironic guys you were complaining
about your stuff getting burned by lava
I exploded
hey Carl yes I need something I mean I I
couldn't explain it any more thoroughly
why that was if I keep you you're gonna
die no just give him to me I'll make it
real quick down here I can make it right
here there's lava away from each other
where the Frick is veterans oh great now
there's a freaking skeleton take it away
you cannot believe that on me I was
fixing why did you need to finish the
water block disappear by the way did you
rent the lava buckets why would you kill
me that was you we lost the buckets guys
diamond baby okay now we can mine
obsidian and we can finally blew up our
only chance of ending this guys I'm on
my breaking point five breaking Boyd's
ago the other senior what the hell is
this I was trying to make okay so I look
like a bum it's a look over there are
you guys just gonna keep laughing guys
go to the base go to the base just go
Chris everyone go to the base no are you
kidding me
I just want to tell you guess what I
have all of your inventory guess
some one thing I'm missing buckets of
course it only burns buckets that was
it's not an infidel lava source we don't
a psyche for you anyway like infinite
lava doesn't exist Christo did Chris it
doesn't exist
we really just have to find diamonds
guys oh it's the only way out
now it's rainy so even the sky is crying
for us get out of it Carl Carl I'm
starving
it was it was Jimmy just what you wanted
okay guys guys Carl I'm on the point of
breaking same I'll tell you that right
now
oh thank you skeleton thank you thank
you for shooting me off that Chris are
you on the point of breaking - I am I
died all right you know what we're gonna
pause here I thought it'd only take an
hour to beat minecraft but it turns out
it's gonna take us like 20 so I'm gonna
make this two parts this was part one
I'll see you guys in part two I'll
upload it in two days after this video
see you on to day I don't wanna die